LIKE BLAKE MASTERS, THEY ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THEM.
>> DON, I WANT TO SEE --
>> I WANT TO HEAR WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT AN EXCHANGE THAT MEGHAN
MARKLE HAD, OF COURSE SHE'S GOT
THIS PODCAST, SO POPULAR RIGHT
NOW, PART OF IT IS BECAUSE IT IS
MEGHAN MARKLE, BUT SHE'S ALSO
GOT THESE HUGE HIGH PROFAIL
PROFILE GUESTS, LIKE SERENA
WILLIAMS, BUT THIS WAS WITH
MARIAH CAREY.
>> FOR US IT IS SO DIFFERENT,
YOU'RE LIGHT SKINNED, YOU'RE NOT
TREATED AS A BLACK WOMAN, YOU'RE
NOT TREATED AS A WHITE WOMAN.
IF THERE IS ANY TIME THAT PEOPLE
WERE FOCUSED ON MY RACE IT WAS
WHEN I STARTED DATING HARRY.
UP UNTIL THEN I WAS TREATED LIKE
A MIXED WOMAN AND THINGS REALLY
SHIFTED.
>> YOU TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS,
DON, THIS CONCEPT.
>> WELL, LOOK, THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF THINGS AT WORK HERE.
COLORISM WHICH I TALK ABOUT.
COLORISM IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
BUT THERE IS ALSO THIS IS ALSO
FOR PEOPLE, IN SOME WAYS SHE'S
SAYING SHE HAD PRIVILEGE.
SO THEREFORE IT DIDN'T APPLY TO
HER BECAUSE IT NEVER HAPPENED TO
HER, RIGHT?
SHE WAS A MIXED WOMAN, PEOPLE
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO REACT
TO HER, DIDN'T KNOW IF SHE WAS
BLACK OR WHITE BUT DIDN'T GET
THE FULL BLACK TREATMENT, PEOPLE
WEREN'T SURE SHE WAS BLACK.
I THINK MOST AFRICAN AMERICANS
PROBABLY LOOKED AT HER AND SAID
I KNOW THAT'S A BLACK WOMAN, BUT
I THINK THE LARGER CULTURE MAY
NOT HAVE REALIZED THAT.
BUT WHAT SHE ESSENTIALLY -- WHAT
SHE IS COMING FROM IS A PLACE OF
PRIVILEGE, WHERE SHE DID NOT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH RACISM, UNTIL
SHE MARRIED A WHITE MAN AND SHE
HAS GOT ALL THIS CRITICISM AND
ALL THIS ATTENTION AND SUDDENLY
SHE UNDERSTOOD OR UNDERSTANDS
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO BE PART OF A
GROUP OF PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY OR IN
EUROPE WHO ARE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST.
SO I THINK IT WAS EYE OPENING
FOR HER.
IT IS CERTAINLY REAL, AND, YOU
KNOW, IT IS INTERESTING MARIAH
CAREY HAS A VERY SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE.
I REMEMBER WHEN MARIAH CAREY
CAME ABOUT IN THE '90s, PEOPLE
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH HER.
IN THE PODCAST, SHE TALKS ABOUT
PEOPLE NOT KNOWING HOW TO DO HER
HAIR, HER -- THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
IN CHARGE OF HER AND TRYING TO
ESTABLISH HER AS AN ARTIST
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO MARKET
HER, DO THEY MARKET HER AS A
BLACK WOMAN, DO THEY MARKET HER
AS A MIXED WOMAN, DO THEY MARKET
HER AS A WHITE WOMAN.
I THINK IT IS AN EYE OPENING
PODCAST AND I COMMEND MEGHAN
MARKLE FOR GOING THERE, EVEN
THOUGH IT IS A BIT SHOCK